what's up you bad [ __ ] I'm
usually showing you pictures of reefer
Leif getting high and we [ __ ] around
I'm gonna introduce you to a cat that's
got more Mike than anybody you [ __ ]
ever met in your life right this guy is
not the best looking to in the world he
kind of smells [ __ ] up from time to
time when I first met him he was a
little [ __ ] kitten and he wouldn't
mess with me at all I called him a super
bad
this guy's got more and [ __ ]
Alvarez's [ __ ] all right this guy is a
[ __ ] look how he bites his [ __ ] he
don't give a [ __ ] but he licks you like
a dog today look at these [ __ ] -
look he's always [ __ ] but this guy you
taste some if I had a million dollars
cash or this guy there was a fire I'd go
for this guy first because you can't
replace this little [ __ ]
he's just most come back from they want
to lick you for a while then it'll bite
you but he's just telling you he loves
you this guy was dead this is the guy I
made a promise that if he would live I'd
never do coke again that was nine years
ago today looking not nine years ago
today but that was eight years ago it's
gonna be nine in November what have you
seen a cat lick somebody so he licks
your hands something like he bites [ __ ]
he licks your hands nobody this is the
best looking cat in the world he's not a
[ __ ] strange mix you know he's not no
[ __ ] or whatever but in the world of
love and [ __ ] you know balls they
stab this cat there was three times the
size this [ __ ]
I'm super bad what after one day and
they fell in a [ __ ] laundry basket
and they almost fought through the
[ __ ] back if I wouldn't got him out
of that this guy's got that was [ __ ]
salute
I'll tell you what you see this right
here I came all about this little guy
then I have these [ __ ] much like
contact every day
this guy's got more heart than [ __ ]
balls this is my shoe bad look he's a
[ __ ] scumbag but that's why I love me
like I always say I don't like nice
[ __ ] people
nice people make me [ __ ] nervous his
savages like this look and he don't bite
me hard
he's just [ __ ] around me they let me
know he loves me look I don't leave the
house this guy looks in my hand I find a
$20 bill
that's how solid this [ __ ]
yesterday was national dog back in my
world his [ __ ] cat they dog day every
[ __ ] day ok that's how I look at
things if you got an animal any [ __ ]
Adam I don't if it's a [ __ ] parrot I
don't care if it's a pennant
you've got a lot of these [ __ ]
everyday because what they bring to your
life
my friends he'll never find that he
works there he goes
that's it that's the [ __ ] minute
report when my main man super bad it's
not all about reefing strangling people
and doing drugs and [ __ ] around
sometimes you got to give animals wealth
so for you national [ __ ] animal
days
suck my dick in my house it's national
[ __ ] cat and dog day and parrot day
every [ __ ] day okay
stay black uncle Joey loves you
[ __ ]